this just in spider-man is set to swing
back into cinemas for an extra-special
rerelease Sony Pictures announced on
August 19th a spider-man far from home
will return to theaters over Labor Day
weekend here's what you need to know
about the rerelease first the most
importantly is a launch date according
to Variety spider-man far from home
story release run will begin on Thursday
August 29th it's not clear how long far
from home will stick around in cinemas
for a second outing though it appears
that maybe a one weekend only engagement
Spidey fans would be wise to clear their
schedules from Thursday to Sunday just
to be safe sony has confirmed that those
in the US and Canada will be able to
attend the spider-man far from home we
release in standard format showings as
well as an IMAX and large format
screenings available at select locations
viewers might want to spend a little
extra money on an IMAX ticket for the
release of spider-man far from home
because it will be an extended cut at
the theatrical version of the film Sony
has included four minutes of additional
footage not shown in the original kurta
far from home the studio is keeping
quiet about what this extra footage
entails but we have a few ideas
regarding what it might be the four
minutes reportedly make up a single
scene with colliders Steve Weintraub
speculating that this sequence will take
place ahead of the main action of
spider-man far from home Weintraub is
good reason to suspect that after
speaking with a director of far from
home John Watts
in a recent interview in which once
opened up about the scenes left out of
the theatrical cut of the movie what's
explain that one deleted scene involves
Tom Hollands Peter Parker running around
New York and completing errands before
jetting off to Europe there's just this
very simple thing where we had Peter
doing errands getting ready for his trip
and that's going back to mr. Delmas to
Delhi that's been rebuilt since it was
blown up in homecoming and he has this
very Spider Man list of things to do
it's like get his passports get the dual
headphone adapter so he can listen to
music with MJ on a flight take down a
giant gang he added that the far from
home team put that scene together as a
kind of short film based on the Intel
what's offered and is sit down with
Weintraub it seems as a solid chance
that the four minutes of extra footage
included in the spider-man far from home
be release could be that little short
film keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation the one question that
remains after learning all there is to
know about the spider-man far from home
rerelease is why sony is doing it in the
first place
well it's tough to say with complete
certainty it appears that those at Sony
are taking a page out of Marvel's
playbook with a far
from home rerelease and maybe looking to
push the film into an even higher tier
of financial success earlier this year
Marvel Studios gave Avengers endgame
re-release that helped the film beats
out James Cameron's Avatar to become the
best earning movie of all time far from
home on the other hand recently became
Sony's most profitable movie ever edging
out Skyfall after grossing one point 109
billion dollars at the global box office
far from home is sitting atop 376
million dollars at a domestic box office
so it's plausible that Sony is aiming to
send far from home past a four million
dollar domestic benchmark with the
upcoming release in any case the
spider-man far from home be release it's
worth getting excited about it may not
feature much extra footage but any time
spent with the friendly neighborhood
spider-man is time well spent
[Applause]
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]